well last week was the worst our country
has seen so far with the exploding
number of new coronavirus infections
in fact the analytics firm evacuar isi
says the midwest
is now under siege states in the middle
of the country
including kansas oklahoma iowa illinois
where they are seeing the biggest
surge of infections to date michelle ram
joins us she is the health care reporter
for the gazette newspaper
in cedar rapids iowa where it's
predicted the number of infections
will double in the next two weeks if the
virus is not
controlled michelle thank you for
joining us how bad is it
uh things are pretty dire here at this
point uh we're seeing alarming number of
new cases each day and hospitalization
rates keep reaching levels that we've
never seen throughout this pandemic
so it's safe to say that local officials
are alarmed
uh they're alarmed and michaela there is
a prediction from the university of
washington that
iowa is going to run out of icu beds
in december in fact what seven of 17
southeastern counties only two have icu
beds available
uh that they may not be able to take
care of iowans who have coronavirus
yeah that's certainly the alarm just
this morning the university of iowa
epidemiologist tweeted something like
icus are filled and they're beginning to
ration critical care resources
so it's definitely becoming a reality as
as we continue on
and what do they do when they start
rationing you know resources
uh you know what are the healthcare
officials talking about you know sending
people with chronovirus
symptoms home if they don't need to be
intubated
uh so we're not quite at that level uh
the university of iowa
hospitals and clinics which is the
state's largest hospital has been um
taking care of coronavirus patients at
home if they have capacity to if they
feel well enough to stay home they have
been doing that throughout this pandemic
we're not quite at that point yet so in
recent weeks local hospitals have begun
reducing elective surgeries um they've
done this in an effort to preserve
staffing capacity and
reserve supply capacity you know they
feel confident that their search plans
in place could take care of all the
patients that do come in
they're really worried about their staff
at this point uh not only are staff
becoming sick and having to stay home
for two weeks at a time but
quite frankly they're a little burned
out they've been doing this for eight
months now and it's hospital officials
are really worried about their capacity
to care for these patients so
at the university of iowa hospitals and
clinics again the state's largest
hospital has begun moving
some of its staff in outpatient settings
into the inpatient settings to help
alleviate some of that need
we're looking at a uh graphic those are
statistics showing how it could double
you know very shortly governor kim
reynolds has for months resisted a
a statewide mass mandate she now says
bash should be worn inside for certain
size groups uh
is it seen that she's done enough uh
look i know you may not have a mask if
you on your tractor out in the wheat
field
but what's the sense of what the state
has done and if they have reacted
properly to what's
an exploding emergency yeah um
so governor reynolds mask mandate is
really a partial mass mandate uh it only
applies to
25 people indoors and 100 people
outdoors um
and you know there are people who
believe that that goes far enough but
there are also
local leaders who don't believe that
goes far enough you know local
municipalities have issued their own
mass mandates within their jurisdiction
the mayor cedar rapids for example has
had a mass mandate in place
since early september you know they they
feel that this doesn't go far enough and
you know there are other local leaders
calling for the governor to go further
especially health care professionals who
were really seeing this firsthand they
they believe that the governor needs to
be taking works out
yeah the the infection started uh
basically in the spring
and the beef processing plants and the
tyson plants
uh now some of your counties have rates
that are 10 times
that of new york city houston new
orleans uh
and other places what do you predict
what do you think is going to happen
over the next few weeks yeah um
you know i i really defer to the public
health officials on this
and you know they're really concerned
heading into the holiday season
um you know at the rate that they're
seeing they're really asking people to
please
cancel thanksgiving plans because
they're worried going into the holiday
you know groups of people traveling
across the state are coming from other
states and
and getting into large groups of people
could really exacerbate the situation
we're seeing right now
it's dangerous it is out there heed the
warnings
michaela rama the gazette the health
reporter there thank you for your work
and